[Music]
and no men allowed me oh my god I kind
of beat up a grandma submitted by Josh
from mother Melvin hey madam L been a
movie theater is attacked online by men
over its plan to host a ladies only
screening of the new Wonder Woman film
that is [ __ ] sex really really David
how [ __ ] mean what if we had a
[ __ ] Superman screaming and we let
any Girls Aloud in there huh that would
imply that would imply it all literally
because Superman flies that would not
fly your [ __ ] would be dry as [ __ ]
cause you can't see that you sound
stupid I don't understand this at all
me neither I'll tell you why yeah well
it's cause like okay so a bunch of girls
want to get together watch Wonder Woman
right awesome yeah CPP why I must stop
this crying on Linus [ __ ] because it's
injustice you know for many years guys
have been living under the shadow of
women we have been living under the
shadow of your beautiful breasts
you disgust there's like possibly 600
other movie theaters in your city so if
that movie theater says it's all girls
awesome so much for a particular showing
- don't even like you know what it is
line up and then me and my dudes we go
watch it somewhere else
we'll go jack off to Wonder Woman
another movie theater it's a it's called
a colic counter whining so like um it's
like well would it be with the other way
around
well it's hot ah no around I'm an idiot
yeah so but that's what that's what it
is so it's like if it would not be okay
for for a man to do that at a Superman
screening why is it okay for women to do
that because it is but it's not fair
like that so what what do you mean it's
not fair like that though because for
like centuries women have always been
oppressed but you're kind of still
bringing up we're talking about
fundamentals you know what I mean so
that's what I'm just saying why people
would do this and it happens a lot so
you got to think about it like invest in
this sense do from where I'm going with
it it's like what if they did
only thing or blacks only but you're
still excluding out certain people
because of us something that they can't
change about themselves so I think like
fundamentally speaking that's why I'm
saying it's counter lining you know I
don't have a [ __ ] issue with it like
I'd get to talks about it you know I
mean oh it's Wonder Woman so late if I
want to do it why not it kind of reminds
me of like girl power baby shower or a
bachelorette party that's that's what
reminds me yeah yeah cuz it just sounds
like it's a girls night out at one
particular theater for one like pot like
one slot so it's not like it's it's a
chain of them that are doing it you know
across the country you know what I mean
then I'd be like well people once again
they get they would get upset about a
restaurant it's not multiple restaurants
but as one restaurant says that likely
point alone but it's my restaurant it
just starts here and then the next thing
you know it's going to be all women
restaurants and the next thing you know
is all women malls and then all women TV
shows and all women everything and no
boys allowed that's what's going to
happen I don't mind cuz they've already
not let me into girls locker room for
the longest time and I won't go to those
girls movie theaters
I've been trying to get to go back to
the locker rooms with a little bit
century they never let me see their
titties my god I've been oppressed you
know how long I've been trying to go
into the locker room
I don't every time I want to we spawn
one of the girls side and then I get
carried out by two security guard that
is discrimination
oh my god discrimination I counter why
anything that you're talking about it
would make sense like just it would be
justified if both sides were equal and
then one of them is saying like no you
can't come because it's whatever reason
but it's not equal like what you're
saying like you know women for so long
I've been presently we just want this
one thing that we can't have because
guys are getting so butter over it I
think it's more like girls are you cold
you talking about I think it's more like
a loving line since it's a [ __ ] movie
yeah right so yeah like it doesn't even
matter
people like complaining for the safety
complain so the Alamo Drafthouse theater
in Austin Texas had announced that they
were going to have this women only
screaming this woman's fun they called
it ladies night screaming that's the
issue is calling it women's only that's
kind of like saying no Asians allowed
only yeah if it was ladies night it'd be
different
it's very different how is it different
break it down because it's less
offensive
it's the wording because it's not saying
no boys allowed it's saying ladies night
so expect it to be a whole bunch of
ladies bonding and if you're there
you're going to feel awkward no they
want like they don't want any men like
the entire staff like everyone that's
going to be working for these particular
screaming they're only women they don't
want missiles at all unless like I as a
woman so the reason why I say that is
because this movie is based on like the
fact that she comes from like a woman's
only world like they wanted to crow that
thing yeah exactly that same for the
screen and it's only two screenings like
it's not the entire time that's not a
big deal I bet the people that are
complaining or even from Texas bottom so
much what the hell that I would love to
be employed that the other me too you
never lie be a man Jewish high level boy
all I am a man I'm sorry
actually I don't want to be it'll
destroy the magic of what a ladies
because we ladies are like ladies in the
in their group and then they're
comfortable there they turn into
different creatures oh that's right
don't don't let that happen to you yeah
the whole movie theaters just parking
while the movies playing because usually
guys dozen mmm I think it's all it's
only the girls I see what's going on why
did I do that or why did I have it come
on you everyone always asking me
questions during a movie I'm just trying
to flirt and give you a romantic evening
but when I watch movies by myself I know
when I watch movies by myself no [ __ ]
you have not want to talk to it doesn't
make any sense
no is the pleasure you know
I talked to the movie thank you very
much no that's what I go to the movies
with you I talked through the movie not
to you my man yeah so they even added
like they all the screaming of these
closer they've already been sold out
also they've even saying like we've
never done showings where you have to be
a man to get in but we did show the
entourage movie a few years ago sound
like a joke and then the next thing that
Alamo Drafthouse says is and these
screenings are just a way to celebrate
the character and how important she's
been to women over the last eight
decades hope you enjoy it we really
liked it for the record if I owned Alamo
Drafthouse I would have been like quit
complaining you [ __ ] [ __ ] these
men were saying well we're going to buy
tickets anyway to show up anyways and
then Elmo judge house is like yeah
that'll show us cuz I got all the
proceeds from the sale of the ticket
sales of these screenings will be going
to women's charity oh dang that's [ __ ]
up although we're trying hard for your
understanding I try to be understanding
I forget it what about the many
charities what about the wifebeaters
Association yeah come on they need help
they need more weapons to be snow lives
with this show this dude right here what
is he - he looks like he's a vampire
something he doing up completing so she
tweeted this out I have some personal
news I like to share and so it's like
the women screaming only and then his
his ticket receipt because he says
that's my ticket receipt on the plot of
rebel yeah so he was like they can help
he verified because he's converted
journalist or writer or something I
couldn't figure it out either
anyways vacant he says they cannot
remove me from a public place for my sex
or gender
I plan on enjoying you're really showing
it [ __ ] you're really showing the man
what
yeah they're not removing your [ __ ]
idiot it's not like you're sitting in
the theater and then they picked you up
and moved you out wow he's really
showing them here some more men butt
hurts man baby seriously Allendale very
tacky Alamo I'm all for equality and
having a screening specifically stating
it is not inclusive to everyone and
against equality
I'm not saying Alamo did it
intentionally but it is still just a
problem oh it's in a box of tissues
here's another one you know famous is
wrong but I knew that please you know
flex is business and I will never set
foot in your theater again I will
actively campaign against Alamo I never
thought I would actively campaign
against a local awesome business but
you've gone too far ye oh hi you're such
a [ __ ] waste of time yes I'm hearing
people are like guys con bemoaning
gentlemen women are paying to
voluntarily remove themselves from your
company for an evening if your focus
should go beyond the business that's
facilitating this and be directed toward
the nearest mirror now uncool honestly
the fact that men can let women have
this warning shows how little we've come
into society some men laid down their
lives
battling white supremacists on the
streets others demand admittance to the
women only Wonder Woman screening oh my
god that is awesome this is a great idea
and I will see you another time
wow that was easier than decided to feel
persecuted I want to see the those same
guys protest at chuck-e-cheeses for not
letting adults in yeah but they must
feel discriminated I feel like you're
trolling dude I don't even think that
that's real I think that's real no it's
real because even someone else tweeted I
hope someone Sue's this is
discrimination based on sex dude a lot
of guys now are not men like it's crazy
like say maybe your period hey hey I
don't like you scream I can't do it I
can do it so I'm done I'm trying to fend
them ah I don't even understand like
let's say they have a six o'clock
showing it's for everybody right and
then the ladies night is
they intent and then the midnight
showing is also for everyone like
they're not discriminating against
anybody it's just those two slots that's
what it's used for
yeah they don't have a sign that says
keep your [ __ ] ass out of here I wonder
if they're protesting it like Lamaze
classes like why is it women only what
the [ __ ] yeah I'd be really upset though
I want to be part of this response class
of the moss class
what are you ever [ __ ] gonna have a
kid what is that really go to Lamaze
lockers that [ __ ] French camel I'm
alone in this pregnancy I know what are
you talking about girl you go see us
good what is my thank you it doesn't
matter you didn't even know what our
baby was dude if I did you forgot I
remember I know when it's due September
mm-hmm
oh yeah this other one I thought was
kind of funny
so this person wrote imagine the
shitstorm if there was any male only
showing up anything or a private showing
for a specific race or sexual
orientation
nah it's sjw or social justice warrior
approved and then Alamo Drafthouse
response to that saying we're actually
still waiting on our social justice
warrior certification for this event but
we're crossing our fingers really
deserves running out so I said that's
well talking about the huh Stacy said
what I was telling us we welcome [ __ ]
it's the counter complainers just to
[ __ ] I want to get like all of these
guys that are complaining and check if
they got a dick
this is [ __ ] I don't think so I think
it's a matter of a dick or vagina
because guys and girls can both be
businesses yeah the part that I'm really
confused is the guys that are
complaining why would they publicly tell
the world that I'm a [ __ ] you're gonna
but why would you do that like I follows
a [ __ ] and I knew I had these bitch-ass
thoughts as my [ __ ] I feel like a little
[ __ ] but on my lease front and keep
these stupid suggestions I think most
people don't want to boldly admit that
they're a [ __ ] I think people do this
generation I look at this I think a lot
of people also both we like to put out
that there's [ __ ] stupid yeah this is
that I don't know if it's Generation Y I
just think the Internet has given a
voice to [ __ ] dumb
yes they have so many avenues to speak
now yeah Facebook no wetter and then we
give them more attention that's a
[ __ ] man yeah and then they have
another little [ __ ] that [ __ ]
confirm their business I'm going to say
that that's that's another guy looks old
so it's not limited to a generation it's
just this day and age there's [ __ ] of
all ages yeah I'm seeing this areolas
like I guess a little hater like yep I
get to the end of me - who had our man
no frustration okay
I don't even on a transit what is it
like - like I'm over it yeah I'm just so
over [ __ ] don't say that [ __ ] again
gets cool I had a [ __ ] [ __ ] man
whatever whenever parallel [ __ ]
whatever oh hey guys hope you enjoyed
that episode please don't miss a beat
and subscribe because if you don't
subscribe you don't know when a new
video is uploaded but for more videos
click up here